I saw a story of a trial in Glasgow 11
people put on trial for witchcraft that
was the headline really sensationalist
in 2023 people are on tral for
witchcraft then when they outlin the
actual charges it was Satanic ritual
abuse of children it was sexual abuse of
children and and forcing children into
seances and use Ouija boards and it was
all it was all jumbled up together it
did get me wondering the weird sex stuff
is is part of it the sex rituals yeah
this part of it and let's come back
again to the blo thing you know why they
use virgins in their rituals when a
virgin woman had sex for the first time
the highman breaks so there's blood so
there is a covenant there so at the time
that's why they use the virgins for the
rituals because there is a connection
there is a covenant there there pure
there's something there with with that
blood that gets the the the demons and
then it gets more power that's why they
also use children